All right, so let's continue
with this idea that this is
really not the time to tune out of politics.
Joe Biden has been chosen by the American people
to remove Donald Trump from the Oval Office.
The U.S. Senate has not yet been decided.
The results so far that Democrats have flipped
two seats while Republicans flipped one. That's
a net gain of one for Democrats. And it puts the
balance at 48 48, with four seats remaining. Now
two of the remaining seats in North Carolina and
Alaska. In North Carolina, it looks like Thom
Tillis, Republican incumbent, will win. In Alaska,
incumbent Republican Dan Sullivan will easily win.
So we have two Senate races that will determine
who controls the Senate. They are both in Georgia.
They are both special runoff elections.
And of course, if Democrats get both,
they get 50 50 in the Senate. In the case of a 50
50 Senate tie, the vice president decides that's
Vice President elect Kamala Harris. In one Georgia
race, David Perdue, the incumbent Republican,
failed to get the required 50 percent in a three
way race. So there will be a runoff on January 5th
against the Democratic challenger, John USCIRF.
Huge race in the other Georgia race. It was the
special election. There will also be a runoff
between Republican incumbent Kelly Loffler,
one of the most corrupt senators in the Senate,
and Democratic challenger Raphael Warnock also
on January 5th. Now I'll be up front. The Warnock
race is much more of an uphill battle than OSF.
Both will be tough. The entire country now
needs to be focused on these races. We now
have two months that will determine can we take
the Senate from Republicans? Joe Biden doing
stuff will depend more on these two races than any
other single thing. And we should be taking it as
seriously as Andrew Yang is taking it. Andrew
Yang tweeting Evelin and I, that's his wife,
are moving to Georgia to help John OSF and Raphael
Warnock win. This is our only chance to clear
Mitch out of the way and help Joe and Kamala get
things done in the next four years. More details
to come, but let's go. And Andrew Yang also
tweeting, The best thing we could do for Joe
is to get him a Democratic Senate.
There should be coordination of resources.
Everyone who campaigned for Joe should get ready
to head to Georgia. I'll go. It's the only way
to sideline Mitch McConnell and give Joe Biden a
unified government. We have a new priority here.
We don't have to you know, when when during
the lead up to a major election, we'll do I
do a phone bank for my senator, although they
have an easy path or do I maybe phone bank for
some other senator somewhere else? How do I split
time? Or what if we can all focus on these two
races? Everyone can get involved, phone banking,
donating. We can all work on these two races
for the next two months. Remember, if you turn
eighteen by January five, you can vote. Let's find
those 17 year olds who will be turning eighteen.
By January five. They can vote. There is a this is
this is the we're running campaigns here, right?
This is the nitty gritty. We have an opportunity
to all come together and we will be talking
about it a lot over the next couple of weeks.